um hello everyone I'd like to introduce
freedom damn loud he's a lead
technologist for supper and they are
also a sponsor for the this event so we
like to thank them for that so I'll
leave the space that they can start
talking about the presentation thanks my
on awesome yeah thank you everyone
welcome to building an army of data
collecting robots in Python if you
thought this was a talk about robotics i
apologize i won't actually be talking
about any real physical robots this is
the the web crawling scraping kind so
let everyone settle in a little bit here
so my name is freedom dumlao i am not
famous but thanks to mel gibson my name
is famous and i also get to see this
picture emailed to me or skype detected
like once a week thanks thanks mel
gibson and all of my coworkers if you've
seen me online you probably saw me
referenced as API guy you'll find me as
API guy on Twitter github bitbucket I
don't have a github repository for this
talk and I'll explain why that is a
little bit later on I used to do a lot
of work there was solely api-based and I
kept that name because it kind of rhymes
so I work for a company called zephyr
and zephyr is the leading SAS platform
for brands media and rights management
on youtube and i've also done a little
bit of side projects if any of you guys
do web development and you've heard of
the framework flask i'm the creator of
the flask extension called flash classy
which gives you class-based views for
your flask applications and i love
talking about it both all the merits and
problems so if you want to talk about
that talk to me later on so originally I
was doing a differ
talk I don't know if you guys were
looking through the the talk
descriptions earlier on originally I was
going to do a talk called OPD yeah you
know me that's a naughty by nature
reference for anybody who didn't exist
in the 1990s and the idea of this talk
was aggregating all of the data that
people tend to make available publicly
about themselves and using that to game
some social media sites and it turns out
you know social media sites aren't that
big on having people figure out ways to
the game them and they sent me you know
a couple of nice letters and I was like
yeah I'm a cool guy I'll just scrap the
talk I've been working on for three
weeks and write in whole new one in
three days so if i skip a slide or if
there's an extra extra slide I apologize
it's I've been cramming on this for the
last few days so why this talk so I am
NOT a data scientist right I am an
enterprise software architect which
means I take small programs and I build
big programs that run on a lot of
different computers and an easier way to
say that it takes something that's
really simple and I make it way more
complicated and I have a lot of friends
though I live in Boston Massachusetts
there's a large data science community
there and I have a lot of friends that
are in data science and a couple of
weeks ago I was talking with a friend of
mine named Linda we were having lunch
and she's a human behavioral researcher
and she has a side project she was
working on where she wanted as part of
the side project to build up a database
of shareable content things that people
might be able to share on social media
and that was the core of it and she told
me she was having a lot of trouble
because it was taking so long see she
set up the system where she could go to
a website and then copy the link and
then paste it into a CSV file that she
was building and it just took forever
like one person manually copying these
things in now this is a person who
actually does know python she spent some
time building scripts and she thought
about automating it but
her it just seemed easier let's just
let's just do this copy and paste thing
but after a couple of weeks you only had
a few hundred URLs put together with
some extra data that she'd collected
about them and I talked to her like why
are you doing this I was really
surprised because Linda's way smarter
than me I couldn't imagine why she would
be doing so much manual work and she
didn't realize that while she was out
there she's getting her information from
the internet she didn't realize that she
could actually be using the internet to
do the work of getting the information
for her so I just found the clicker I
don't have to walk back and forth as
much so before we dive into what what
Linden I built that afternoon let's just
talk a little bit about what data on the
web looks like I think you guys are
mostly going to be familiar with this
stuff so there's obvious one is HTML
right this is everywhere it's a Bic
witness you've probably seen some JSON
api's where you can get this data it's
nicely structured and easy to parse
Python handles this extremely well if
you take a time machine back like 10
years you'll probably be stuck working
with a lot of this stuff or if you're
working with the AdWords API anybody
from google here so this is what the the
most of the data is that we think about
on the internet but there's a lot of
other data right there images or videos
there's source code the programs there's
data sets like actual data sets you can
just download and start using audio data
there's data about the activity on the
internet like how long did it take me to
get a response back from a server how
many network hops that I have to get
there and then of course there is
metadata which is everyone's favorite
now right this is the the talk of the
day but i'm not talking about this
particular metadata just so you know
metadata is its data about your data and
we've been doing this for a long time
right HTML 1 point 0 has a tag called
meta that's used to describe the data in
the page that we kind of used early on
because we wanted to force yahoo to
think that our web page was the best web
page they just copy that keyword like a
thousand
times but metadata has grown quite a bit
and we've come to appreciate it more and
there's this really cool protocol called
the Open Graph protocol which I believe
was born here at Facebook the Open Graph
protocol lets you describe the content
so that it can be used as a social media
shareable item really easily so she
wanted to find and build data and build
a database of searchable shareable items
open graph is the stuff that she should
have been looking for right away she
didn't know about this so this is where
we started so this is what open graph
looks like this is a really simple one
but it's just using the the classic HTML
meta tags with these properties with the
special OG type there's a few required
ones and then there are dozens of
optional ones that you can use but this
is the reason why when you share
something on Facebook it doesn't just
look like a link it ends up looking like
a nice little formatted box with it with
the title and description and maybe a
playable video player in there so Linda
and I sat down that afternoon right
after lunch and we started building our
very first robot and we wanted to keep
it really simple so we wanted to do
these four things we wanted to be able
to read a list of URLs that we would
pass in download the HTML from each of
those URLs find any open graph data that
might be in there believe it or not not
everybody is using open graph right now
and then just print that back out so
this is pretty simple system this is how
we wanted to be able to use it right
just pass in a bunch of URLs those
social media company names look familiar
so this is our very first robot now
before I go any farther I'm not going to
be doing a lot of showing code in this
presentation I assume a lot of you guys
have seen Python code and if I talk
about it you'll probably be able to
conceptually realize how you would put
something together but this is a
starting point and a couple of times
I'll reference this code later on as we
go this is really basic we're using the
open graph
library to strip the open graph data out
it gives us a dictionary like object
that we can work with later on so this
is our first robot and this is our
initial system architecture so we have a
user who puts a bunch of URLs into a
robot and it dumps it out onto this
console and linda was super psyched
about this when she saw this going
because she took that list of urls that
she had been collecting and passed it
right in and got back out this nice
formatted possible dataset and it just
like it buzzed right along the screen
she was so psyched and I said did you
remember all of that she said no of
course not because it's all on the
screen and the buffer ran out so we need
a way to save the output of this script
right we can't just look at it and
remember it when we go to run our next
program so this is the first problem you
have to solve you have to save it so I
asked Linda I said how are we going to
save what just came out of your script
and she said easy we can just write this
to a file right no big deal she just
added the little carrot operator in the
name of a file she wanted to all dumped
into a file and we were good so I lied a
little bit earlier I didn't actually let
her run her entire file before I let her
just run some of it and we control seed
and quit as it was running so once we
had this she actually started running
the whole thing and then she started
thinking like okay well I want to add
this URL i want to add this URL but this
first robot wasn't done running yet
right and we didn't want to stop it so
she just wanted to run another robot and
another robot as she was thinking of
more URLs you could add them in and
pointing them all at this file now does
anybody here see a problem with this
particular system architecture the file
was crap like there's this was
completely unusable she didn't expect
that to happen she thought you know it's
a computer it's going to take care of
this and it it does take care of it you
just don't get anything useful in the
end so she was a little baffled and I
said how would you solve this problem
and her first response was do she said
well what if we use XML
xml is not a database so we talked a
little bit through it and she came up
with this she'll dump it out each
process to a different file and then
when she's done she can gather them all
up together right maybe another Python
scripts to just mash them all together
and concatenate them and then she can
load that data into her tool of choice
by the way this is probably the only
talked that you guys are going to see
where you're not going to see anybody
presenting like pandas or scikit-learn
or any of those tools I am she uses
pandas I'm aware of pandas so the first
problem with this solution is that we
have multiple files we don't know how
many there are going to be and we have
to figure out a way to put all that data
together the second problem is I can't
start reading this data until all of
these little robots are done right I
can't just start picking up files that
are half written I don't know if I'm
going to get good data I'll probably
break whatever it is I'm using to parse
that up and the next problem is what if
I'm getting more data than my computer
can actually store or handle what if I'm
getting so much data that I can't load
this up into memory so what's the
solution to this it's something we've
all heard of right you need a database
to put your data in I always thought
this was an obvious thing but I I also
probably set up databases every day of
my life and it wasn't just wasn't part
of Linda's day-to-day experience so
there are a lot of databases today if
you do a web search you'll hear a lot
I've heard about several new ones while
I was here at the conference and there's
a question which one should i use and
really the answer is it doesn't matter
what the one you should use is the one
that you can put data into and get set
up and get working with as soon as
possible you can change this later on if
you build your application correctly so
for for Linda and I she wanted to
actually be able to do some fuzzy
searching stuff on this we chose
elasticsearch I convinced her that it
was the right choice because of the
fuzzy searching but really I liked it
because elasticsearch auto
matically persists dictionary like
objects really easy and it meant I only
had to write one line of code to to get
us to the next step so before where we
had that line that said print the open
graph data we just replace that with
this there's a little bit of
configuration for for elastic search but
really this was the big the big change
in our architecture so now Linda can run
as many of these robots as she wants as
long as the elastic search database is
running and dump the state it in there
and she can search on that data set
while these robots are still running so
that is a huge win she's totally
satisfied and she's ready to go home and
start playing with what we built but
there's still another problem right
which is how fast can you type urls in
and it's probably pretty fast but not as
fast as a computer can do it so what we
need is something to get URLs for us
well just so happens we're downloading
HTML pages right to get this open graph
data every single time we download that
we've got a whole new resource of URLs
anchor tags that we can scrape out and
search those as well so now she doesn't
have to type in as many do or else we
can keep looking for new data and new
open graph data as we go so our second
robot very simple just calls it just
takes this URL downloads the data finds
the links and then uses those links to
open up a new process to call the
original robot and this works great
right now look at all these things look
at all these robots this is great like
now this is starting to feel like an
army of robots and they're just cranking
away and cranking away until eventually
your computer isn't going to be able to
continue to do this forever it just
isn't going to you can't just keep on
making new processes at a rate like that
so I presented this challenge slender I
said how do we do that she said well
what if we just took these URLs and
we'll put them in a file that we can
read out of and I said oh you want to
have all of your robots
write to a file to read later on and she
remembered that that didn't work so well
before and so I said what's the solution
she said well how about a database and
that's a good idea we can write these
things into a database and then read
them efficiently that's a good idea but
how do I know when one robots already
working on a URL and another robot comes
along I don't want two robots or three
robots or all of my robots working on
the same URL at the same time and you
might say well yeah i could write to the
database and say i'm working on it but
really as fast as computers work the
chances that one robot is going to pick
that up and start working before the
next robot realizes that somebody else
is working on it very high so we need
something different to solve this
problem and so that's when by the way
this slide should have been there the
whole time I was just talking sorry
about that we need a task queue you'll
also hear things like message queues or
job queues all fine all ways of solving
this particular problem but the idea is
you find a piece of work that needs to
get done and you put it in one end and
then from the other end the robots can
pick these things up and process them
and that way each job gets one chance to
be worked on if it fails you can pop it
back in the other end or come up with
some other failure handling strategy but
this is how we can structure it so for
us moving fast we picked RQ RQ is really
lightweight queue management system it
uses Redis which is just another kind of
database to store the queue States and
our queue is really easy to work with
that in that name equals main part we
were talking about earlier instead of
having it just pipe through all these
URLs instead we replaced it with this
which opens up this queue and just
starts working which means nothing until
you actually add stuff to the queue so
in order to add something to the queue
you just pass in the function and
whatever parameters it's going to need
to work on so now we have this
architecture set up Linda can put stuff
in the queue the robots can put stuff in
the queue they keep working they keep
cranking data gets in the database she
can come back later and
her searches and she can run a whole lot
of robots and gather a lot data a lot of
data a lot faster than she was able to
do manually and the great thing is is
that she can now leave right she can
walk away from this process because each
of these robots is continuing to find
more URLs and put them into the queue so
this process keeps on working more data
continues to be gathered so now what we
have a working system something that
Linda by the way is very very satisfied
with at this point she's ready to turn
on her laptop and walk away from it and
let it gather up these URLs but really
what happens when your computer turns
off what happens when the battery dies
on your laptop what happens to all of
this data what they've been processing
fortunately the database is going to
store that day pneus you'll be able to
still use that but you stopped working
you stop processing and how much work
can one computer actually do especially
Linda's she has a little laptop that she
got from work so we need more power than
what one computer can do by the way this
is the first Star Trek reference I've
seen at the whole conference I'm really
disappointed so I thought it was among
my peers here so we need to use the word
I hate more than anything ever the cloud
right which is just a really fancy way
of saying the internet but when you say
the cloud it means something special to
people in marketing departments so you
have to use this word if you want to get
your project approved so so yeah so
we're going to use the cloud and we have
already identified there are three
services that we're going to need right
so the first service we need is a
database and we've already decided we're
going to use elasticsearch now Linda
studying this up this is a side project
so she's not building an in-house inside
of her her company that she works for
but fortunately the cloud delivers there
are so many of these elastic search
posted website solutions so we picked
cubox I oh now I just want to make
everyone understand I'm not endorsing
any of the companies that I'm putting up
here with the exception of the one that
I work for I am just giving you some
options so if you're trying to set
something like this up you know that
somebody else has used this successfully
it'll work for you too so Q box gives
you 35 actually get started up that
sounded really good to Linda so we set
up our elastic search on q box the next
thing we needed was a task queue now you
don't actually need special software to
run the RQ portion of this you just need
a rightist database somewhere and
reddest go who has the least screenshot
apple website ever they're really cheap
and easy to get started with as well so
we have a red as database in the cloud
we have our elastic search in the cloud
the last service that we haven't really
thought of as a service until now is
compute we need something to run our
little robots and make them continue to
run while we're not watching so shallow
budget and we were running out of time
we wanted to do this by the end of the
afternoon we chose Heroku Heroku is a
platform as a service system that you
can put little units of work into and
it'll just keep on working a lot of
people use it for web applications I
like to use it as a bunch of little
clustered data processors so there's
three steps to setting up a Hoku
application since we hadn't talked about
setting up a compute service before step
one create an application step to get
pull the application and step three add
requirements a text file at a proc file
commit your changes and get push your
application three steps really simple
the last ones a little stretch but so
this is what a requirements out text
looks like for anybody who hasn't seen
one this is a standard Python
requirements on text her oak is going to
read through that and install those
packages for you and your in your
machine the proc file just says give me
a name and tell me what you want me to
run for that name and that's all we
really wanted the proc file to do and
then we deploy by committing our changes
that we just made the proc file whatever
and we push it up it's running now once
we push that up it's running I was
looking for by the way for an image of a
bunch of these little tiny dogs running
because these are little robots but this
is the best I could find so it's running
we need more power now how do we expand
how do we get the cloud to deliver well
Hiroko is really easy you just do this
and now we've got 20 workers running our
application so now here we are at a
starbucks in Boston which is a very
controversial place to be because dunkin
donuts is the right place to sit and do
this in boston but where r at starbucks
and we have this running we just started
on this when we were having lunch
earlier on and she's really psyched
about this because now she can scale
this up this cluster of 20 robots costs
about a dollar an hour to run plus the
cost of elastic search which he's got
for free for about a month and register
go was she's paying I think seven bucks
a month for so oh hey I forgot the most
important part of this it's in the it's
in the cloud
so so now it's I mean now it's official
this is real yeah we've legitimized the
whole thing so now she can build this
thing she can deploy it she can set
these things off to go gather up data
from all over the web she's satisfied we
finally in the in the conversation and
and that's it I was really amazed that
she wasn't aware that she could have
done this herself because it really took
us I think a total of maybe three hours
to set this up and get it running but
then I was kind of glad when I started
thinking about this too because we have
to think about this responsibly we are
all members of the internet community
right and it sounds really generic and
and some like artsy or whatever but it's
it's actually true we all live our lives
in a way that's connected to the
Internet and it's important that the
internet stays a safe place and rule
number one when you build a system like
this is do not denial of service attack
your neighbor right it's really easy so
imagine that first cluster or that
cluster that we have of 20 workers
running right and it finds somewhere
along the line somebody's like retail
shop that's running on a shared host at
PHP server it's their business you know
they're they're very happy and now all
of a sudden it doesn't work because
there's 20 requests happening all at one
time trying to gouge out data from their
website so you need to think about this
before you turn something like this on
how are you going to prevent somebody's
website from becoming overwhelmed there
are some really easy strategies right
like put some delays on each iteration
maybe there are more sophisticated
strategies with maybe blacklist and
white list of URLs and if you'd like to
talk about more sophisticated and cool
strategies talk to me after this talk
this by the way is the reason why I
ended up not posting my working code on
github because somebody pointed out to
me that if they started with a set of
URLs that were somebody they didn't like
they would have just built a
denial-of-service machine and they
wouldn't have to do any work for it
the next rule is that this thing was a
web crawler now yours might not be a web
crawler right we can apply these same
principles to something that isn't the
internet you could build these workers
that are out probing humidity sensors
and a factory somewhere right it doesn't
necessarily have to be the internet but
if you are on the internet there's this
thing called robots text and web
developers everywhere know what this is
but other people might not robots text
is a file that you can place at the root
of your domain and it has rules that
says this is the parts of my site that I
allow robots to crawl these are the
parts i don't want you to crawl you
should obey these rules or you will
probably find your robot being banned on
that domain the last rule I know I hope
this rule is something that everyone
applies universally in their life but I
understand not all of us can and that's
fine too but in this case please think
about what you're doing when you're
running this much power at one time when
you're making this much network
bandwidth happen at one time think about
who's going to be affected and consider
that even though yes you can turn this
thing on and slurp all that data down as
quickly as possible when you do that
you're using bandwidth that somebody
else isn't going to be able to use so
like let's say you are in a dormitory or
something like that and setting up a
little internal cluster you're using up
all the bandwidth and now nobody can use
bittorrent or play xbox probably going
to take some people off so now that we
talked about some responsibility let's
talk about some of the gotchas that
you're going to face when you said
something like this up most of these
gotchas our web related so number one is
large files as your thing is crawling
along if it grabs that happens to find a
URL to a 20 gigabyte web movie or
something like that your robot might
just download that so pay attention to
things like the content type right like
that is one of the headers in that file
that'll tell you what the content is
supposed to be that helps but also set a
limit maybe create a buffer that says
like after I've consumed this much data
Bale give up because I don't actually
want to use up all of my ram next thing
is I just said look at the content type
but don't trust it because I can create
a content type that's completely invalid
for any file right
it's up to me i own the web server so
just because it says its HTML don't
trust that it is HTML but if it says
it's not HTML it's probably safe to pass
on it in this case and then recursive
URLs this is a tricky one so one website
that points back to another website that
points back to one website points back
to another website this happens this is
a real thing and you're going to hit it
and it's going to turn up but you might
not even see it depending on how your
logging is set up and it's not try to
think of a better word to use them what
I was about to use because I got really
angry when I hit this one the first time
years ago it's not that people are out
there trying to stop your web crawler
from working but people are out there
trying to stop your web crawler from
working and even though you can take
this URL and put it in the log and say
okay I've hit this URL I don't want to
hit it again it's very trivial for
somebody that is set like a querystring
parameter something they now changes the
URL and so you're seeing it as a new URL
but it's really not and you're going
back and forth that you'll hear terms of
for this thing called a honeypot you
know for people who are trying to set
these things up it's a death trap
because it can consume all of your
robots and now you're spending a dollar
an hour paving the same URLs over and
over again so the data is out there my
talk is is coming close to an end here
go get it responsibly please so that's
the end of my talk really before you
guys get up and go again my name is
freedom dumlao i am going to be
releasing something related to this talk
on github in the next week or so once i
have it vetted by some people who will
help me make sure that i'm not deploying
a das machine for everyone to use if you
follow me on twitter at api guy or check
out bitters follow me on github you'll
see when that comes up I work for Zephyr
one of the sponsors of this event we're
currently running a challenge right now
where if you can describe a
an HTML file that comes off at the end
of the URL in 140 your code needs to be
less than 140 character needs a fit
inside of a tweet you could win an ipad
mini we're also hosting an event tonight
which is in the Zen garden there will be
drinks and food and stuff like that and
we are definitely hiring so anybody have
questions yes sure the code needs to fit
in the tweet that's the challenge and we
do have some working solutions we have
some creative solutions I think the
first submission what it output was it
we just take the URL and then it would
output the URL is insecure in IE and
that is a valid description of that URL
I'm absolutely of any URL i pass in
there so that was pretty clever we've
had some other creative ones as well so
I'm interested to see o people come up
with because when you put a weird
constraint like size on it now we python
is the ideal language but you know I
think you probably look at submissions
in other languages as well yeah so any
other questions great well thank you
very much everyone and I look forward to
seeing the rest of you at the
Oh